[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
when you were young and your heart
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
say
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
what
when you got a job
[Applause]
[Music]
you just
[Music]
living life
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
live
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
rock and roll is here to stay
[Music]
it's better to burn out
than to fade away
[Music]
my my name is
[Music]
they give you this but you pay for that
and once you're gone you can't
ever come back
[Music]
when you're out of the blue
and into the black
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
king is gone but he's not forgotten
this is the story of johnny rod
it's better to burn out
than it is gone but he's not the god
[Music]
there's more to the picture
than meets the eyes
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
it ain't me
[Music]
but when a tax
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
me
there is a house
in new orleans
[Music]
[Music]
i knew i won
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do
[Music]
oh mother tell your children
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sun
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
to wear that
[Applause]
[Music]
there
tape
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i know i'm one
[Music]
dude
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when you were young and your heart
[Music]
living right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
living life
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
but she was more like a
[Music]
what do beauty mean
she told me her name is
[Music]
don't go around breaking young
[Music]
who you know
[Music]
[Music]
just remember to always
[Music]
[Music]
dance
[Music]
but you came
[Music]
oh
[Music]
she's a singer
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
carol
tomay ceo of ups
thank you and good afternoon everyone
welcome to the ups atlanta gateway
this is one of 96 gateways that we
operate
across america and as you know atlanta
is the headquarters for ups
so we are honored to be hosting today's
meeting with mr presidents
welcome to ups i'd also like to give a
warm welcome to secretary chao
and secretary perdue and of course
governor kemp
and all of the state and federal
legislators and delegates who are here
with us today please give them
a warm welcome
[Applause]
you know ups is a company of almost 500
000 dedicated employees we deliver
packages in more than 200
countries and territories our ups
automobiles our packaged cars put on
nearly 4
billion miles every year that's billion
with a b
yes indeed and we operate the ninth
largest airline in the world
so we know just a little bit about
transportation you know we're honored to
be essential workers
every day our upsers they deliver
ppe hand sanitizers
medicines and essential goods to
americans
and people across the world we're
honored
to do that and you know we couldn't do
that
if we didn't have infrastructure in fact
our ability to serve our customers our
ability to drive economies
our ability to run an environmentally
responsible company
well it wouldn't be possible without a
strong infrastructure and that's why
we're so delighted
to have president trump here today to
talk to us about
infrastructure but before i bring him to
the stage
i want to give a shout out to the upsers
who are doing this good work
every day
so proud of you thank you
thank you for all that you do we're here
to talk about infrastructure i know
president trump has a lot of good news
to share with us today
so it is my pleasure without further ado
to introduce the president of the united
states of america
mr donald j trump
[Music]
and i won't forget the men who died
who gave that light to me and i gladly
stand up
next to you and defend her still today
bless the usa
thank you very much everybody thank you
thank you
great honor please thank you sit down
please
it's great to be with you great company
and
wonderful location quick flight it's in
and out but we have some big things to
say
carol i want to thank you also for doing
such an incredible job at this company
i look at your numbers and i'm very
jealous a lot of people are very jealous
but i'm delighted to be back in atlanta
georgia
special place
the hometown of one of the most amazing
companies on earth ups they never fail
the dedicated men and women of ups are
an inspiration to us all in the face of
every challenge you always come through
for your fellow citizens would you say
that's correct i say it's correct
let me start by expressing my gratitude
to every driver worker and employee
who has contributed to this great
success and
continued to deliver for america
throughout our battle
against the china virus goes by many
different names about 21 that i can
figure we maybe will use a different one
every time we hit it
but whatever it is it was a terrible
thing and it could have been stopped and
it should have been stopped right where
it started in china
together we will defeat this virus and
emerge stronger than ever before
we're here today
[Applause]
to celebrate a historic breakthrough
that will transform the lives of workers
and families
all across our nation for decades the
single biggest
obstacle to building a modern
transportation system
has been the mountains and mountains of
bureaucratic red tape in washington
dc before i took office reviews for
highways ballooned to an average of
nearly
750 pages in length and they were the
good ones they were the short ones
and i know because i was in business for
a long time and i had to go through a
process that
was so ridiculous it was so ridiculous
we went through a process for
building buildings usually it would take
forever
by the time you start building the
market changed you said you know the
market was good when we started now the
market's lousy so you say the hell with
it
we won't build sometimes you start
building you say that was a mistake
but we went through years and years of
litigation
and tumult and it was just not good but
you go through it
to an even greater extent the maze-like
approval process represented lobbyists
that were very rich they were making a
lot of money i remember i'd go up to
albany new york and i'd see my lobbyists
up there
i said what are you doing here i knew
what they were doing they were trying to
make it more difficult
so you had to hire them for more and
more work spend millions and millions of
dollars for nothing
but too often they caused massive delays
on top of everything else
and that way they got their fees over a
longer period of time
it's one of the reasons why for example
the average atlanta driver spends an
incredible 77 hours in traffic
during a short period of time but all of
that ends today
we're doing something very dramatic
[Applause]
we just completed an unprecedented and i
want to say it's absolutely
unprecedented
top to bottom overhaul should have been
done years ago
of the infrastructure approval process
this approval process
that has cost trillions of dollars
over the years for our country and
delays like you wouldn't believe
this is a truly historic breakthrough
which means better roads bridges tunnels
and highways
for every ups driver and every citizen
all across
our land together we're reclaiming
america's proud heritage
as a nation of builders in a nation that
can get things done
because with these horrible
roadblocks that were put in front of us
you couldn't get it done no matter how
good you were
you couldn't get it done you'd wait and
wait you'd go to the next step you say
you can't start the next step
until you finish the first joining us
for the special occasion our
council of environmental quality
chairman mary newmeier where's mary
mary thank you mary thank you
thank you thank you mary good
secretary of transportation a very
special woman a great woman
somebody that has done an incredible job
elaine chao
elaine
and she was very much instrumental in
getting this done and when
elaine speaks we all listen but she was
very much
instrumental secretary of agriculture a
man who's done a fantastic job for our
farmers and ranchers sonny perdue
sonny
i learned more about farming from sonny
perdue than all of these consultants
that came in i learned more in a half an
hour from that man right there
we had a great call today with the
farmers too great call
they're doing very well a lot of good
things have happened right sonny a lot
of things have happened they were
targeted by china
they were targeted by others we just
signed the usmca which is phenomenal for
our country and our farmers
got rid of one of the worst trade deals
in history nafta
one of the worst trade deals ever how
anybody could have signed it
but worse how anybody could have let it
run for
25 years or whatever it was they just
took advantage of us we had 60
000 empty plants and factories in our
country by the time that mess
got finished so we just signed a great
deal usmca it's the largest trade deal
ever made mexico canada the largest ever
made
i know sonny would like me to thank the
ups
all of the drivers and workers for all
of the help
in delivering nearly 30 million meals to
rural children throughout
the country for our meals
to you program meals to you you know
what that is meals to you
you do right we're also pleased to be
joined by
a great senator somebody that's done a
phenomenal job and i can tell you look
he's a friend of mine so i'm a little
prejudiced but
he's a man that's respected by everybody
on both sides of the u.s senate
he works hard he loves your state and i
always say does david get the kind of
recognition that he deserves because he
is a very
very special man david perdue where's
david
david thank you
and a woman who's come in and done a
great job and she's been so supportive
of me and the agenda
and a good person a good woman
with a husband who's a terrific man
senator kelly leffler thank you very
much
thank you kelly great job kelly
and warriors these are warriors these
people fought for us through
thick and thin through very very unfair
territory we were treated terribly and
they came in and they turned out to be
tougher than the other side by a lot and
i just want to
introduce representatives rick allen
rick
thanks rick the great buddy carter
buddy
an incredible spokesman an incredible
man and friend
doug collins doug thank you
great job doug drew ferguson
drew thank you very much drew
[Applause]
heist jody thank you jody great job jody
and barry loudermilk barry thank you
very much
and also two people friends of mine
they'll be there soon in my opinion
because they have to be because we need
all the help we can get in washington
karen handel karen thank you very much
thank you karen and rich mccormick
rich thank you they'll be there soon i
hope
i hope we need them we need them get
them in there
thank you as well to a man who i became
very good friends with a man
who uh was running against somebody that
was unbeatable
running against a superstar i said oh
she's a superstar wow
can you beat superstars i don't think so
but he figured out how to beat a
superstar
and i don't know if she's still a super
celebrant i'm not sure
i'm not sure i don't think so i don't
know superstars don't lose do they
governor brian kemp
i'll tell you what what a warrior he is
he's tough
he's tough and he's done a great job and
you've done a great job in every aspect
of running this
incredible state and i've always been
there for you he was saying when we met
at the plane
everything we've needed in georgia
you've been there for and that's right
that's right perhaps more important than
brian however
right far more important is georgia
first lady
marty kemp thank you very much marty
[Applause]
[Music]
and watch please those mail-in ballots
you're going to watch that for me
because you know they have a lot of
problems all over the country they just
had paterson new jersey
where massive percentages of the vote
was a fraud mail in balance be careful
be careful they would understand because
they deliver in fact i'm gonna have to
be very nice to
ups ups i love you carol wherever you
are carol
i love you carol no it's very bad what's
going on with mail-in ballots
okay as as differentiated from
absentee ballots where you have to go
and you go through a process because you
can't be there
for some reason but the mail-in balance
is going to be
they're going to be rigged they're going
to be a terrible situation and you have
to be careful in georgia but you have to
be careful everywhere where they're
doing it
you know we went through a first world
war and a second world war and people
went to vote now they're
saying let's use this as a chance not to
vote
and there's been tremendous corruption
tremendous corruption
on mail in balance so absentee ballot
great
mail-in ballot absolutely no good it
makes no sense
a governor sends out millions of ballots
all over the place they don't know where
they're going
they're going to wherever i have a
friend who got
one for his daughter another one for his
daughter and then a second one for the
first
daughter they didn't know what to do
with him i had another friend a
really wonderful guy who's lost his son
seven years ago
robert his son robert and his son was
sent a mail-in ballot he called me he
said what do i do i just got a mail-in
ballot for robert robert died seven
years ago
so it's uh it's a terrible situation
if they decide to use it and we'll see
what happens there's a lot of litigation
a lot of court cases right now
and it makes sense just think of it
millions of ballots in california
they're sending out millions of ballots
they don't even know who maybe they know
too well who they're sending them to and
maybe it's the people that don't get it
maybe it's an area of republicans or
democrats that don't happen to get any
ballots
we've had a lot of problems just take a
look at what's gone on over the last
month and take a look at paterson new
jersey
small city in new jersey i think they
said
something like 20 of the ballots were
corrupted or something happened with
them 20
and even in the 2016 election one
percent are in question
but i don't want to talk about that one
because i won so i don't want anyone
going back and looking
all right i'm not going to talk about
2016.
that was the greatest election and now
we have to do something very important
we have to keep it going
or this country will be in big big
trouble
i want to thank also for being here
georgia attorney general chris carr
you're the one chris
watch that chris will you you're going
to watch that chris please okay
you got to speak to the man that handles
it you know what i'm talking about
got to do it thank you chris it's in
good hands superintendent richard woods
richard thank you very much thank you
and members of the georgia public
service commission and the state
senate and house transportation
committee he's got a lot of politicians
in this room
and really good luck to karen and to
rich go out and
go get them great people today's action
is part of my administration's fierce
commitment to slashing the web of
needless bureaucracy that is holding
back our citizens i've been wanting to
do this from day one
and we started it on day one literally
on day one but it takes a long time you
have statutory requirements you have a
lot of
different roadblocks even to changing it
but the change you'll be hearing about
in a minute
and it's one of the biggest things we
can be doing for our country
the last administration increased the
federal register
by 16 000 pages of
job-killing regulations under my
administration
we have cut the federal register by
nearly 25
000 pages more than any president in
history whether it's four years eight
years or in one case more and we frankly
this i would think is maybe the biggest
of all
we did the u.s waters you saw that the
u.s waters act that was a big one
that was a big one i thought i was going
to take a lot of heat when i did that
and instead it was just the opposite
people came up grown
men that had never cried even when they
were a baby they were standing behind me
when i signed that bill
at the white house and they were crying
they were crying because we gave their
life back to
them that took their life away it took
their livelihood away
it was a big big moment but this is a
big moment today too
probably possibly equally as big
today's action completely modernizes the
environmental review process
under the national environmental policy
act of 1969
we are cutting the federal permitting
timeline from
a staggering 10 years 15 years
18 years 21 years you know the story
you've seen it
projects that start out a young guy
heads the project by the time it gets
approved or disapproved in many cases
disapproved usually disapproved he's
getting ready to retire
so what did you do for your life i
worked on one project we didn't get it
through in the end
now we won't get certain projects
through for environmental reasons they
have to be environmentally sound but you
know what we're going to know in a year
we're going to know in a year and a half
we're not going to know in 20 years
so we're cutting the federal permitting
timeline for a major
project from up to 20 years
or more hard to believe down to two
years or less so we have it down to
about two years right now elaine and i
think two years or less
and our goal is one year and you may get
disapproved
it may they may vote at the end they
didn't like something environmentally or
safety-wise
and i'm all for that but you're not
going to devote a lifetime
to doing a project that doesn't get
approved or that gets approved
and oftentimes when it gets approved it
comes in at 10 20 30 times the cost
there's a highway in a certain state
short road not even a highway i guess
more of a roadway
and they put in it was a straight line
from point to point
by the time they finished it 18 years
later it was this
it cost tens of times it costs
many many many times more than the
original
is a dangerous roadway because there's
turns you've got to be in good shape
you've got to be wide awake
to make those turns you're going to see
those things you have to see the guard
rails bomb
they had a simple straight roadway and
now they build
they end up took 17 years to get it
approved ended up costing many many
times what the original
estimates were and it's no good it's not
good
under the last administration a mere
seven percent of reviews for federal
highways
were processed within two years
now what we're doing is the two years
won't be the exception it'll be the rule
so what we're doing is we're going to
have that coming down
at a much steeper rate this will reduce
approval times for
highways alone by at least 70 percent
but the 70 percent is a very uh
unambitious number because the number is
going to be actually much lower than
that at the heart of the reforms
is the one federal decision policy
it really spells it out when you hear
that name one federal decision
before applicants for infrastructure
permits were forced to spend
years and years navigating a labyrinth
of
federal agencies and every single one
had
a power to stop a project anytime you
went to an agency they had a power to
stop it
and it would stop the project not only
stop it right in its tracks it would
stop it
with our reforms there will be one quick
and fair decision
we're going to give every project a
clear answer yes or no
yes or no the two-year process where
just to submit
is two years is not acceptable it's
going to be a very quick
yes or no after study but the studies
are going to go quickly and they're
going to go simultaneously
so if you're in numerous agencies you're
all going at the same time
instead of waiting for one for two
for three and oftentimes you'd go
through one it would take you six months
and then you have to wait 90 days and
then you have a review period and then
you start the second one
and now you go for another four months
and then you wait 90 days and you have a
review period
and sometimes you had to go through 9 10
12
different agencies so even if you did
absolute rapid it was many many years
before you could even think about
starting it
we have up here by the way that's a
chart of the old system and the new
system
and i think the new system is better i
think it's better not only in time
i think it's better in terms of the
process and i think it's better in terms
of
the importance from an environmental and
a safety standpoint but
take a look at that this is what you had
to go through
in fact it was much more dramatic when i
first
came up with this about a year ago we
took that and we rolled it out it was so
dramatic
and it just kept going and going so the
difference is
that and many of those steps you had to
wait before you could even think about
going to the next one
and you had to get full approvals any
one of those
colors where there was a problem or a
rejection meant it was dead
and now you go through this very simple
but very comprehensive
solution it's a beautiful thing
especially if you
understand construction and building and
other things beyond building
like i do at the same time we'll
maintain america's gold standard
environmental protections
the united states will continue to have
among the very cleanest air and cleanest
water on earth
which we do now we have the cleanest
that we've ever had
meaning ever meaning i guess in the last
40 years i assumed that 200 years ago
was cleaner
i can imagine it was very clean a couple
of hundred years ago brian right they'll
say
that's why i'm very careful with the
fake news media because
if i say that we have the cleanest water
we've ever had they said what about 200
years ago before
anybody touched the lake when the lake
was a beautiful virgin lake nobody ever
touched it
they said uh yeah they got me on that
one don't they huh so now i become
extremely uh careful so i always like so
i say probably they're talking about 35
40 years something like that if it's any
different from that media we will
look at all those people back there any
different than that we will report to
you
we will make an amendment we will we'll
never make a correction because i don't
like doing that
one of the first projects accelerated by
these reforms will be the planned
expansion of i-75
right here in georgia that's in honor of
your wife in honor of marty
okay that's in honor of marty they've
been looking to do that for many years
right
but the governor is going to get it done
this expansion will add 77 new lane
miles of commercial vehicles
like those driven by ups saving drivers
countless
hundreds of hours a year with us today
is julian park
a teamster i know the teamsters very
well
at ups who drives this route often
julian please come up
and tell your story please thank you
[Applause]
thank you good afternoon hi my name is
julian park
um it's a great honor in front i'm
especially grateful for my wife being
here with me today for 14 years
um
[Applause]
i spent the first 16 years of my career
driving a package car going from house
to house
but in my last three years i've been in
the big rigs
mostly on 75 and throughout 75 we have
approximately 765
trucks in metro atlanta 64 of those
travel from mcdonough to macon georgia
which is about 100 miles round trip
so with the congestion and all of that
it it kind of
makes it to where it's hard to get there
and create all the time commits
so every time i've loaded my truck
whether it was
medical equipment a gift to someone's
you know a loved one
that time in transit was very important
so
with the infrastructure is is very
important to me and all of my fellow
upsers
because the investment in our roads and
bridges help reduce congestion
and open up the bottlenecks which makes
it easier
to get the packages where they need to
go more importantly safe for drivers
like myself
because we all know the most important
stop of the day
is when i get back home to her and my
two beautiful kids
so
thank you 14 years ago at my local hub
in forest park with the support of my
management team
i started the corporate health and
safety process and throughout that team
we were able to lower the accidents and
injuries which we know
accidents on the road slows down time in
transit
so we're able to since then we've
stopped all of that or most of it
so i'd like to close by saying thank you
to my wife for being here
um to everyone that has supported me
especially my division manager tom
rozillo he supported me in my career
and for the grateful opportunity to be
here today
fantastic job thank you julian
but julian it looks like you're
attributing a lot of your success to
your wife is that a correct segment
huh would you please stand up so lovely
thank you
that's great great job you proud of the
job he just did i think huh
pretty good he'll be running for office
next week watch
great job julian thank you i'd like to
invite
ups's vice president of corporate
transportation bill taylor up to say a
few words please bill
thank you bill thank you thank you very
much
good afternoon no thank you for visiting
the ups gateway
president trump thank you very much you
know i am so proud
to be a 37-year veteran of this great
company
i started my ups career as a part-time
hourly employee when i was still in
school back in 1983.
when i graduated from college i went
into management and throughout my career
i've had the
the opportunity to work in our airline
in our freight transportation operations
and also in our package delivery
operations throughout the united states
i'm now preparing to retire when i think
about ups
you know all of us at ups and jillian is
a great example all of us at ups
work through some very tough times
through our careers whether it's
hurricanes and natural disasters
or some type of national event like 911
but all of us at ups also look at that
as a great opportunity
to serve this great country and help
bring the country through and remedy
those tough situations
you look at project airbridge under the
trump administration and working
directly with fema
another great example from a ups
standpoint we are
all tremendously proud to help deliver
life-saving supplies
wherever and whenever they are needed
from an infrastructure standpoint
i know firsthand that improvements in
our infrastructure
will be a tremendous benefit to not only
our customers but also the communities
that we serve
but when i think about ups i know how
strong our technology is
i know how strong our flexible
multi-modal transportation network is
and i know all upsers are dedicated
to making a difference in helping bring
america forward
so as i think about the ending my career
i am very grateful to retire with a
strong pension plan
i hope the same for all essential
workers who have a pension
plan currently hung up that they can
enjoy the same when their work is over
so thank you ups for a wonderful career
and the great opportunity to work with
so many wonderful people through the
years
to help make a difference thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much bill and good luck
carol i don't think i'd let him retire
he looks
he's got about 30 years left in him at
ups
can't believe you're retiring that's
terrible
do you want to retire do you want to say
because they'll renew you for 25 more
years you've got it
you've done a fantastic job thank you
very much thank you bill
really great job here as well as the
commissioner of georgia department of
transportation
russell mcmurray russell please come up
and say a few words thank you
[Applause]
thank you mr president mr president it
was an honor for me to meet with you in
washington dc at the usdot
with secretary elaine chao and some
other state d.o.t
commissioners from around the nation for
us
to share with you this long
burdensome often bureaucratic process
and you sat and listened to us with
great detail
that day and today
at the end of that meeting too i might
add that the president told us
the d.o.t commissioners there in the
room that he was going to streamline the
environmental process
cut the red tape and make sure that the
environment is protected number one
so today is a full circle day for me mr
president
that here we are today with the
president and the trump administration
rolling out yet another not the first
but another
environmental process improvement that
will make life
much easier for people like us at the
departments of transportation across the
nation
to deliver infrastructure projects like
the i-75
commercial vehicle lanes to move that
freight out of savannah
to atlanta and beyond while providing a
safe corridor
for the many families that travel on
i-75
now i certainly want to acknowledge
someone else that is laser focused on
streamlining government
and cutting red tape and that's our
governor brian kemp
governor i appreciate your focus to
transportation and infrastructure
it certainly makes my life a lot easier
so thank you
now finally i'd just like to recognize
somebody else and the president
acknowledged her
earlier but the leadership exemplified
by secretary elaine chao at the usdot
is exceptional we have never experienced
the kind of cooperation
we at the georgia dots never experienced
this type of cooperation from your
administration mr president
that we enjoy today so thank you for
your leadership and thank you for the
partnership you share not only with
georgia but all the states
mr president thank you for making this
happen thank you
and russell said that so well because
there have been many steps that we've
made
over the course of the last three years
that allowed us to get to this big giant
step this is a big deal
and this is uh front page all over this
country and
and frankly uh nobody realizes what it
means
other than the people that are in this
room and others that do what you do but
the fact is
this is something that nobody thought
was possible but it was all those little
steps russell that allowed us to get to
this step
uh bureaucratically and in every other
way so uh thank you very much and you've
done a great job appreciate it
[Applause]
we're also joined by janille king a
small business owner here in atlanta
janelle please come up and say a few
words please
[Applause]
thank you mr president thank you
governor kemp um and thank you ups for
delivering all my shoes on time
i am janelle king together my husband
kelvin king and i
he's the one that really goes through
all of this i serve as vp of external
affairs with osprey management which is
such an honor
we have 10 employees that are by which
one of them
received their united states citizenship
this morning so that's awesome
we have over 150 subcontractors
we have and we have a number of projects
that are taking place throughout the
state
and our ability to harness opportunities
and and supply our clients with on-time
projects properly is extremely important
several have proposed fantastic ideas
and aid to developing new forms of
commuting
red tape and restrictions in place have
hindered these ideas
and have extensive and due to extensive
permitting and impact studies that
increase timelines but mr president you
have shown
what leadership can do when you reform
the old way of doing things
infrastructure reform and building new
roads faster will not only help our
company to achieve our project goals
but they will hurt the entire state both
economically and
socially so i would like to personally
thank you
for placing the needs of the
constituents in the forefront of your
list and addressing our infrastructure
concerns
and our governor and first lady for
working along with you and so we can get
this done
and to our senators senator david perdue
and senator kelly lefler
for always being available as well thank
you so much
[Applause]
and look how proud your husband is of
you he had that camera up that camera
wasn't moving down i'll tell you
he captured every word that's great
beautiful family thank you very much
one of the things i'll tell you that the
governor and i are working on a couple
of projects that are going to be big
surprises for you
big ones big projects that you've been
talking about for 20 years i guess in
one case
so we'll get them done i'm sure we'll
get them done
and i want to thank you all great
presentations thank you all very much my
administration is also moving
full speed ahead on improving the port
of savannah
which is now the largest agriculture
exporting port in the entire united
states
[Applause]
largest in the country as many of you
know this project faced
20 years of unnecessary delays this has
been going on for
years when they came to me and the
governor said can you help us with this
i said we'll help you with it what's the
story it's been going on for years and
years they've been
talking about it nothing ever happened
it was also eight years of additional
bureaucratic reviews just reviews this
isn't like oh gee let's start
digging this is paperwork people made a
lot of money
it's a terrible thing it just gets
caught up like so many other places but
it's all ending now bureaucratic reviews
under the
obama biden administration have been a
disaster
and they got worse but i'm proud to
report that for
three straight years under my
administration we've delivered full
funding for the port of savannah
and we're on track to complete the
project in
a very short period of time it's going
to be completed right
okay in honor of the governor
in honor of the governor and marty good
congratulations that was a great job
they've been fighting for that one for a
long time you got it done
we want a governor that gets it done
even though he calls me all the time can
we get it done
i wish you wouldn't call so much but you
know that's the sign of a good governor
right what do you think right
stand up please that's the sign of a
governor
[Applause]
i like the ones that don't call brian
where they just leave me alone but their
project never happens
great job you do great job we want the
united states to compete and win
in the 21st century and that means we
will not allow our nation to be
hamstrung
by wasteful washington regulations we're
the nation that built the golden gate
bridge
in four years the hoover dam in five
years
and a lot of people don't understand
this but it's so true
we built the empire state building in
less than a year can you imagine that
the biden administration our past
vice president opposes think of this all
of our permitting reforms
and wants to increase the length of the
permitting process
think of this this is in his bernie
sanders deal
biden is happy to tie up projects in red
tape
and we want to get things built but they
want to increase the length so they want
to increase it
from that to much longer
unbelievable biden wants to massively
re-regulate the energy economy
rejoin the parish climate accord which
would kill our
energy totally and you'd have to close
25
of your businesses and kill oil and gas
development
they still haven't explained what
they're going to do to power our great
plants and factories
but at some point i'm sure they will
we'll learn that from aoc who's in
charge of energy
she's in charge along with bernie it's
aoc and bernie are in charge of energy
i don't think texas is too happy about
that what do you think
you think we'll call up the governor
governor abbott great governor will ask
how do you like that governor i don't
think i didn't want to waste the phone
call
because i wouldn't know how he felt and
biden wants to hold hostage billions in
federal surface transportation grants
for states and localities unless the
states and local suburban communities
abolish
single-family zoning rules so they want
low-income housing to be built in
communities that frankly
they don't want it they don't want it
has it worked out
and we're terminating that as you know i
announced it two weeks ago we're going
to be eliminating that
rule it's a crazy rule and it's very
unfair to a lot of people a lot of
people are very unhappy
it should not take 10 years or more just
to get approval
for a simple stretch of road special
interest in washington will never begin
they will never begin to let you breathe
they will never start their business
their business is the opposite
and we will do vetoes wherever necessary
in order to make sure everything happens
and happens quickly
we're not giving a veto for one thing
america's future there will never be a
veto
for america's future so my goal my
mission and my
commitment to each of you is very simple
america's infrastructure will be the
envy of the entire world
as it was many many years ago we built
the interstate highway system
during the eisenhower administration a
long time ago
and since then it's gotten worse and
worse and worse
and more bureaucratic and more
bureaucratic
and now we're freeing up and we're going
back probably to around 1952
we're going back to a long time ago and
again you have to get permits
we want safety we want to be totally
involved with the environment we want
our environment to be better than it
would be the other way the long way
but you're going to get your answers
quickly one way or the other you're
going to get those answers very quickly
and
if the answer is a big beautiful yes
you're going to start construction
immediately you're not going to wait
around
for 10 12 and 20 years our bridges
tunnels freeways and airports will no
longer be the site of shame
but they'll be a source of pride from
coast to coast
town to town we're constructing new
roads railways runways and waterways
you know we had a many cases where
they'll get
federal funding to build a highway that
it'll take them forever to get the
approval
and by the time they have it approved
they need 10 times more money they come
back to the federal government
and the government would usually turn
them down they say that wasn't the deal
but sometimes they just paid 10 times
more
we're not going to do that anymore we're
linking our cities with leaming highways
and blazing fast
broad walk and and if you think when you
look at the farmers of this country what
they've gone through with the broadband
broadband is so bad in the middle
section that beautiful
middle section of our country our
farmers our ranches are hurt very badly
so we're getting fast broadband networks
and we're carving them out and towering
beautiful new monuments to american
greatness and that's what they will be
but our farmers have to be thought of
also nobody thought of our farmers
our farmers are incredible and they're
doing an incredible job
doing an incredible job so for the
farmers out there
broadband here we come broadband they've
been trying to get it for
a long time many years together we're
building our incredible future
with american hands american heart and
american steel
as your president i'm more determined
than ever
that america's infrastructure we'll be
second to none and in georgia you're
going to have an infrastructure and
you're going to have some projects
announced that
almost all of the people in this room do
not know about
most people have given up on them brian
i think they've given up they gave up
with the rest of them but we have some
things
planned in georgia that will be really
incredible
and everybody's going to want it both
democrat by the way and republican the
problem is
nobody was able to get it done we get it
done one thing i know i know how to get
things done
because under this administration
and under this administration we will
always
put america first we were putting other
countries first
now we're putting america first so i
want to thank everybody
for being here i want to thank and
congratulate ups
on having a great run many years but a
great run recently
you've done a fantastic job whether it's
skybridge or
anything else that we've done with you
you've been fantastic i want to
appreciate i really appreciate it
but especially i appreciate a state
called georgia it's a special place
it's a great place and it's an honor to
be with you
and it's an honor this is where i'm
announcing this is good for the whole
country
not only georgia this is for the whole
country but i'm announcing it in georgia
because we have some great things
planned for you
you are special people mr governor thank
you very much marty thank you very much
everybody
thank you thank you everybody thank you
very much everybody
have a good time
[Music]
stars
[Music]
people sleeping in their shoes
[Music]
don't feel like
[Music]
[Applause]
free
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
never get to fall in
[Music]
free
love
[Music]
[Music]
you